i like to confess that i'm a sex addict
and i think about sex
every second of the day
pretty much
[Music]
so lucas
what would you like to confess to today
well today i want to confess that
actually apart from my mom and my dad
nobody knows that i was in prison for a
few years what was the crime i went to
prison for the robbery this is the way i
was making money back in poland you know
when i was at high school i got nearly
caught kissing one of my teachers
i would like to confess that one time
when i was driving my car off the drive
i accidentally got a bit too close to my
brother's brand new saiya avifa
and scratched the side of it
and uh led him to believe that it was
done in a car park
i actually remember that scratch as well
you thought he was doing an aldi and it
wasn't
i did it like two weeks before that
this is the first time you've heard this
yeah like i knew there was a it was like
a significant scratch as well it wasn't
like a little scratch
it's like the size of your hand
i can't believe i've never told you that
so what do you think what would they say
if someone's going to see this from my
family so like i'll put my hands up you
know i've done the mistake in my life
but
i'm doing well now and
i don't know i'm just sorry that i
was not able to let you guys know i
recently got scammed out of a foot pick
so i i get like a lot of random messages
on instagram asking me
stupid things like do you need a sugar
daddy or
can you send me a foot pick if i send
you money i've had that a lot and um
i
last week i was struggling financially
so i hit one of these guys and i was
like do you still need foot picks
and
he was like yeah and he convinced me
that i needed to send one picture of my
feet and then he would pay me money and
then i would send more pictures and we'd
be rich
but
i ended up sending him a foot pick and
getting absolutely nothing out of it
apart from being a bit violated and
embarrassed
i would like to confess today that i
burst into tears every day
after work when i get home
and this is something i haven't spoken
to anyone
so i'd like to confess how i lost my
virginity
is a little bit wild so i haven't told
anyone this yet
basically we're on holiday
went out with the hotel reps and i lost
my virginity in a foursome
with yeah two other guys and a girl
i like to confess that i'm a sex addict
and i think about sex
every second of the day
pretty much
and how does that manifest itself in
relationships
seems to like i've never had a
relationship before because i'm um i'm
scared of commitment and
i have big trust issues as well
so it doesn't really happen so it's just
mainly one night stands
i lost my virginity at 11 years old and
not many people know i don't think
anyone knows so 11 years old how did it
happen so young for you i was unsure of
my sexuality uh deep down i probably
knew i was gay and i didn't live in that
much of an accepting area in order to
find out if i was actually gay or not i
thought i might as well try sleeping
with the girl and since then i've been
living as a openly proud gay man
my biggest regret
is
the resentments occurred towards my
parents um
both my parents were
heroin dealers and heroin addicts
i was raised in a they brought me into
crime and i was kind of left to just
raise myself i've come to realize that
it weren't my parents
behavioral fault that led me into a life
of crime it was my choices
i didn't get a chance to say how i felt
to my parents because they both died of
hearing over those while i was in prison
i just want to say sorry mom and dad
yeah i love you guys i love you
a couple of friday nights ago
and unfortunately i went out got a bit
too drunk maybe
made the mistake of eating a spaghetti
bolognese before when i was
gone out
thought i'd let loose what i thought was
a safe little fart
ended up in my white boxes
all of the girls around me started
dispersing going uh what's that smell
luckily my mate had walked off at the
time so i was like oh it's definitely
him that's disgusting
ran off to the toilet
made myself a little nappy straight back
out
did what i do best pulled the bird and
took him back to the premier inn
today i'd like to confess that um
in high school i struggled a lot with
eating disorders and self-esteem issues
and then when i came to uni and i tried
drugs i found out it was a way to keep
my
weight at a
standard which i liked and
worked to suppress my appetite and
because of that i got really
dependent on them and i ended up
spending
a vast amount of money on them and i've
never really admitted to anyone how much
i've actually spent on the drugs
i'd like to confess today
i'm an ex-career criminal
arrested for the largest importation of
cannabis into the country back in the
day and i've seen the devastating effect
that it's had on children grown-ups
communities
and and because i participated in that
i'm here today to say i'm extremely
sorry to any person who received
anything that i sold i humbly ask for
your forgiveness today and i'm really
sorry i'm at ex-military and i'm now a
teacher and i suffer from anxiety and
depression
if you had a message for someone that's
going through something similar to what
you've been through what would that be i
think you've got to find someone to talk
to i'm i'm so lucky i
in my darkest days i think when it was
really bad and i didn't think there was
any way out there i had i had my family
and my wife and my daughter and if they
weren't there i'd have been in trouble
something i'd like to confess today is
that i'm bisexual and nobody knows about
it
i've never really told anyone because
i've got quite a religious family and i
think if i told them they wouldn't
understand or
their relationship would be a bit ruined
and i've never told my friends just
because i don't know how they'd react
and i don't want to lose friends over it
[Music]
was there a moment for you michael where
you realized you wanted to change your
life you wanted to change things yeah
there was a big moment in my life i was
arrested at gunpoint put in prison with
my father and there was a moment in the
prison cell when i'd had enough
and i i knew about recovery and
the 12-step program but there was a
poignant moment in my life when i knew
that there was something far greater
than me which helped me recover
and now i try to put something back by
working with all sorts of people who
suffer with mental health issues
addictions um you know i've seen both
sides of the coin
and um you know i'm happy to do what i
do today from the experiences i gained
from being in the dark side and now i
work in the light
[Music]
nobody knows that i was in a
relationship with a girl when i was
younger that was a good relationship to
be honest but yeah no one knows that we
were together people still don't know we
were together so this is this is my
first time telling you lot
nobody knows i'm just realizing no one
knows i was with a girl